Everyone, uh, welcome
to toxic Google today.
It is my absolute pleasure to introduce
Sir Ben Kingsley and Patricia Clarkson
for learning to drive.
Let's hold on
anywhere you'd like
stage. Is this working? Oh,
it's working. Hello. Whoo.
Google.
I'm diggity diggity uh,
so thank you so much for joining us.
Your latest film is learning to drive.
Do you mind telling us a little bit
about it? How many of you've seen it?
Good. And the rest of you will see it
when it comes out this yesterday, right?
You will flock and you
will take all your friends
and you will scream and cheer when
our names come up on the screen.
Um, uh, it's a beautiful story about, uh,
uh,
two separate worlds coming together.
It's a woman,
a of fierce intellectual in
New York book critic, uh,
who pretty much has everything but forgets
to realize you has everything. And,
uh, her husband walks out on
her and into her life comes,
um, this exceptionally beautiful and, um,
patient and kind and admirable man.
Yeah.
Um,
emphasis on exceptionally and sexy and
amazing and extraordinary and one of a
kind.
And, um, uh, and, uh, through,
uh, the process of learning to drive
shit 50. She's a hardcore New Yorker,
never driven. She learns to
drive for the first time at 50.
And of course she has a the one and only
Sir Ben Kingsley is her teacher and she
learns, uh, and they learn
many things because he's on a,
uh,
a new path.
They both set out on new paths and
the paths collide and come together.
And in a,
I think a unique and surprising ways.
I think those of you have seen the film
will allow me to describe the form as a
poem. So I have been referring
to it all day as a poem.
And at the beginning of our time we
see a woman in complete distress,
almost completely destroyed by the
disintegration of her relationship.
And at the beginning of the poem
that's called the first stanza, um,
she hates men.
She will never trust men.
She's lost her faith in man. Now, for
those of you who've seen the film,
and those of you haven't,
I will go right now to the end stanza.
Oh,
the film where,
because of her relationship with this man,
she's able to say something very special.
Now the heavens will in our poem,
the heavens will look down and see a
woman in great distress who's lost her
faith. And the heavens
say, I know what we'll do.
We'll send her this warrior,
this pure Ma'am silent.
That's what she needs.
And by bringing them together in,
as Patricia will tell you,
a very confined space, a
car, a little vehicle, um,
which,
which is rather like the ferry in the
archetype of fairy man who will meet you
on one bank of the river,
puts you in his little boat and take
you to the other bank of the river.
But wa on your voyage,
you realize as you step off his boat,
I've learned something.
Something's changed in me forever.
The gift of the ferry man is that he is,
or she is a great teacher,
a great giver of life and
an a show or of the way.
So when we get to the end of our
poem with this particular fairy man,
she's able to say from utter
devastation at the beginning,
you are my faith.
So that's a remarkable journey.
Um,
that lasts the whole length of the film.
It's very delicately handled
verse by verse by verse.
If I can continue calling it a poem and,
um,
the unlikelihood of the pair.
Is there salvation?
I honestly think that if Wendy had
said to somebody in our office,
I'm in great distress, what should
I do? She got all the wrong advice,
particularly from your sister,
um, uh, in the film. Um,
and if, and, and I, um,
I am in the throes of,
in anticipation of an arranged marriage,
uh,
and learn from my friendship. Uh, sorry.
He learns from his friendship with Wendy,
how to bring his Punjabi wife who's
terrified of New York out into the world.
And I think how to love her. I think he
learns how to love her through Wendy too.
So it's, it's quite, uh,
uh, quite an extraordinary,
but I think at the end of
the day, it is a, uh, uh,
a beautiful story about adult friendship,
about true profound meaning and, uh, of,
of a real friendship and a,
a,
a friendship that,
um,
has changed them for the rest of their
lives and end it ends in just the right
place. I don't want to ruin
anything. It ends in just the right,
there won't be a sequel.
Well, if there's enough
money, but now, uh,
let's talk about faith for a moment
because that is such a huge part of it.
And I think,
I think the character of
Wendy is definitely someone
who in the beginning it's
just completely lost her in men.
Not,
not in the religious sense, I mean, in
men and men. But also I think there's a,
isn't there a moment where she just
goes, I'm, I don't believe in God.
I'm mad at you, or God bless. But yeah,
no, I don't think when he was ever
particularly religious woman, but I think,
I think faith in general,
I think she's lost trust and belief
in and a lot of life, right? Suddenly,
you know, a woman who was often
the smartest woman in, in any room,
um, top of her game, uh, a
major critic in a tough city.
And suddenly,
uh,
she is forced to go from a incredibly,
very valuable intellectual
life to this visceral,
um, uh, life, this life that is
uncomfortable for her to be in.
And she has to navigate
her way out of that.
And, uh, it's a journey. I, I relished.
It was not easy,
but it was a journey I relished taking.
I think that they are connected by words,
their love of words.
My father in the Punjab
was a university professor.
My character's father was a
university professor and I,
to my character to a
Donavon sing was a unit,
a university professor in
the, in the Punjab. And He,
he has to migrate away from his homeland,
a terrible loss.
But he does take with him in
his DNA that need to teach,
that need to hand something
on that needs a slight,
that needs a slowly alter for the
better the lives of others. So,
um,
there's,
there is a commonality in the intelligence
and that's very, very important.
It is,
it is a film dealing with two people
of equal intelligence who meet,
greet and salute one another.
Uh, as, as loving friends.
It's nice to see a film
about smart people.
Um, yeah, no, it's, it's wonderful to see
that. But it's also, it's interesting,
it was interesting for me to see this
character and your character who it's his
faith is such a whole part of who he is
and he's very unshaken in it for most of
the time.
But then there's this event in his life
with this impending marriage that maybe
does have an effect on that.
And so what was that sort of,
that journey like for you?
Ooh,
I was very fortunate when I was
filming Gandhi in India to have,
um, uh, seek, uh,
bodyguard driver who drove
me to the set every day,
who protected me on set all day
and drove me home in the evening.
And he was a man of amazing
stillness, very protective. And,
um,
I,
I certainly drew upon my acquaintanceship
with him over those months,
um, on, um, on my portrait of a,
of Darwin. Um, I think that, um,
we must be careful of the word faith.
I think that his faith
allows him to be still,
it is not, um, a,
a faith that needs to be historically
demonstrated. It's, it's not,
um, it's not external.
It's not externalized. Um,
there are scenes in the temple of,
of,
of great stillness and dignity and
family unity and enormous respect.
We were allowed to film in a Sikh temple
not long after six where were shot in
their own temple. So that was
a huge gift. And by Osmosis,
by being with my wonderful
driver body guard,
by being with my one or two seek
friends with whom I'm, I'm quite close.
And then of course, our dear Harpreet
Singh tour on the sell to who,
who put my turban on
everyday quietly dig it, man.
Make a gentlemen. I would like to
make, uh, forgive me if I'm wrong,
I'd like to make a slight generalization.
I feel that if you know
one Sikh gentleman,
you know them all because
there's something extraordinary,
Lee consistent about their moral compass
and their ethics would, would, would you,
would you agree with that?
Yeah.
Good.
I can go home.
Thank you.
But no, I, um, I must say,
um, uh, you know, as you know,
I was, it may have been attached
to this film for a very,
very long time and I love the
character character of Wendy,
but what I will say is in,
and this story in this journey,
but one of the most beautiful aspects of
shooting this film was getting to know
the Sikh community, getting to
know her preach and, um, uh,
an awakening to,
you know,
to this incredible and beautiful culture
and the fact that they embraced, uh,
this film and embrace her. Ben. Well,
who wouldn't want, Sir Ben playing you?
Come on. Um, uh,
but that was valuable and
incredibly comforting,
um, for all of us with
the film that we had them,
we had their blessing, so to speak
with this film. And, uh, but it was,
um, uh, a beautiful lesson
and, and, and journey for me,
one that I will carry
for the rest of my life.
Getting to know the Sikh community.
It's, um, very, uh, it's a very,
very beautiful thing.
Whilst we, Patricia and I have
been talking about this phone,
a retrospectively revisiting it,
um,
I find that I have many thoughts
about the film that I didn't have one,
I was shooting and I've just had one city.
Yeah. Right now. And there's
this, hold on and it's this,
your Wendy,
the very modern meets
the very ancient, yes. He who
will not cut his beard. Yes.
He who will not cut his hair.
He will always wear a turban.
And he who carries a sword.
It's as if,
yeah,
he's traveled.
Thousands of
Sikhism hasn't been with us that long,
but hundreds of years to be with you.
And he learns,
you learn some ancient truths from him.
And I learned some modern truth from you.
And I hope to impart them to just
lean my, my, my arranged bride. Yes,
I know. Yes. That equals
yes, it's, it's in New York,
but the heavens look down to someone
in distress and say she doesn't want a
modern guy. Let's not
send them modern guy. No,
let's send a warrior
from the past. Uh, and I,
I think that that's just hit me sitting.
Yeah.
But you are, I mean,
that's, that's the beauty.
And what I love also about the film is
as strong as the Sikh community and the
beautiful life that is present in
this film. At a certain point. Um,
this film is really just about two adults.
Uh,
at the end of the day it
is about two people, um,
who have different cultures,
but even the cultures fade.
And it really just at the end of the
day is about two people finding a better
life and a better self. And, um,
I think that's what cheers me most
about this film is that it is,
um,
at the very core of
film about humanity and,
and how we can cross divides in subtle and
simple ways. And, uh, I,
I hope you find that and
see that in the film. Um,
that's a wonderful point. And, and as
you mentioned, it's about two adults,
but at least in the u s like
learning to drive is a very,
it's kind of a landmark of this, this
journey into adulthood. You know,
getting your driver's license is
something, I think every 16 or 18.
Now you're all once and
it's this badge of honor,
but these are two people who've
passed into adulthood, you know,
and now they're kind of facing
these maturity decisions that are,
it's probably putting them back into
this kind of like teenage place of mine
almost. Um, you know, how did that
play into it at all for you guys?
Did you see that as a part of the journey
or was that just kind of a Oh, yes.
I mean,
learning to drive both learn, um, uh,
the, the enormous amount of information.
I think the number of times at
Donovan sing asks when d questions,
what should I give her? How
can I talk to her? I mean many,
so many questions in subtly
disguised or quite, you know,
quite quite overt. So the, the, the, the,
the two way flow between them, uh, um,
both learning and bringing them mature.
Mine's two baby steps,
but it, it, it is also for me,
the real true physical act of
driving. Again, s as Patty,
my driving had lapsed. Sadly,
I'm, you know, I'm was born in,
raised in the great city of New Orleans,
and my father taught me to drive at 16.
Um,
and I was a driver.
And slowly as I became more and more
new, Yorker became more Wendy's. So,
and I lost my ability to
drive. And as, and we,
when we arrived at this film,
I really had not been
driving and you know,
Serbinis trust
that I could drive him through
the streets of Manhattan.
I thought, oh my God. I said,
Oh my God, I'm driving Gandhi's
[inaudible].
Oh,
I was very passive.
But through the course
of shooting this film,
I became a better driver. And through
the course of shooting this film,
I realize so many things
that Wendy had to learn.
I mean it was life and art mixing in,
in,
in his vast and fabulous
and precarious ways.
Um, oh, driving over the
Queensboro Bridge, uh,
everyone was like, didn't you have a tow
truck? Didn't you have a stunt double?
I was like, you look at, uh,
but in the course of shooting this
film and truly learning to drive again,
I learned all the lessons that
Wendy had to learn. I had to learn,
have to listen, to look, to pay attention,
to be present,
to take in the world,
to be selfless to,
you know,
to read the signs, to read
the signs. And I realized,
Oh my God,
I haven't read a sign in so long.
I haven't looked up and taken in the
world right in front of me in so long.
And it was a very,
it was a very powerful experience for
both of us shooting this film at all.
Jenny as aren't. Cause when life
and art, when they do coalesce,
it's quite an extraordinary
feeling and journey. Ah,
it's beautiful and it's at its best.
It should always be like that. Yes.
You will.
You always hope for that
when you're shooting a film
to come out the other side,
a better person having more
knowledge. Maybe having, you know,
a new lover you always once,
I did not move.
I mean, you want, you want
to have taken, you know,
you want at the end of this journey.
But I mean, I'm making light of it,
but it was truly a,
a profound experience for us at
the end of this film. It was,
it was difficult to leave them behind.
We went to do a talk at AOL and,
um,
we saw the end of the toy.
We saw the trailer or something together.
Yeah. And we both thought,
oh, we missed the,
in Darwin, we missed them. Uh,
I have a very dear friend who saw
the film the other day and he really,
he loved it. He's an academic,
he's brilliant. And he said, I,
I want to have coffee
with Wendy and Darwin,
not you and Sir Ben,
Wendy and Darwin.
What we,
what we hope as actors,
because I'm skeptical of messages.
I have to be honest.
I think that sometimes if you,
if you respond to a question
regarding what do you hope for,
what's the message of it?
Clutters you.
So all I all I would like to
say in terms of this film,
and I know Patty agrees with me, is that
audiences, audiences who see the phone,
we'll have thoughts pop in their head
that they would not have had had they not
seen the film.
That's all we can hope
for. That I think is that's
what we can help for.
That is somehow makes you think about
something you hadn't thought about before.
And,
you know,
I know that this is a film
starring two people who are not 25,
but I will tell you something.
I've had my nieces and nephews,
I have 10 of them. Oh my God.
It's why I didn't procreate.
It's enough. There's enough of us. Um, uh,
and they,
they were surprised at what they,
what they felt about this film been there.
Like they range from
25 to 34 or something.
And so I think,
um,
this is a film that can resonate with
people of all ages and all cultures and
all backgrounds and,
uh,
we've played a very diverse
audiences and they have responded.
So I, I hope, um, when you see it,
those of you who have not seen it,
I hope you, it takes you somewhere.
When I was, I think I told
you this story, um, when I,
when we were with the
Hollywood foreign press, Gosh,
was that yesterday or the day before?
Where are we now?
We're on a whirlwind tour then
we're in, we're at, we're in,
it says it that Google
got it. Um, the Internet.
I am Palo Alto. Fuck.
One of the, one of the,
the very last into interview of
the day and had done several,
um, was a young woman probably in
her late twenties, early thirties,
from Belgium. And I started, um,
as I introduced our talk,
as I introduced myself to you,
I started with that idea of the poem
and have the woman in total distress,
lacking faith and trust
in men and the heavens,
looking down and sending her the warrior.
And I looked up,
whilst I was talking,
tears were streaming down her
face and this was on camera.
And I said,
you know,
for the s for the sake of you
and I in this conversation story,
please keep that in your broadcast.
She said, well, the, there's no choice.
Of course I will keep it in my
broadcast. This was, this was this,
these are the generation that you're
alluding to. She found it deeply,
deeply touching. It just hit a nerve
in her, which is very gratifying. Yeah.
It's great to make girls cry.
I don't have any Oscar nominations.
I can't cry right now. I'm sorry
man. I don't know how
to follow that up. Um,
I'm gonna, I'm going to talk
about New York for a moment. Okay.
New York is a wonderful city and
it's also one of the places that one,
it is terrifying to drive in. Like
I used to live there and it's, I,
I do not want to drive over the bridge.
I was terrified for you
guys in that moment. Um,
but it's also one of the only places
in the world where I could probably see
something like this happening with this
culture kind of meshing and where yes,
it's just totally normal for all of these,
you know,
groups to cohabitate and stuff like that.
But there's also this kind of moment
of discrimination and, and you know,
raids on onward I is living. Um, I think
it's something people often forget about.
Um, that happens, you know,
I think maybe we focus a lot on
other immigration issues. Um,
but it's one of those things where you
think, oh, New York melting pot. No. Um,
so, and, and you guys got to shoot in
New York City. Um, so what was, you know,
did that add extra to it?
It actually getting the students end
up in front of a green screen as you
mentioned it,
it adds a lot.
We had, you know, when I was first
trying to get this movie made, you know,
everyone was like, well, could we
shoot this in Toronto? I was like,
yes, let's drive around Toronto. Um,
uh, someone actually
said, I love this film.
If you cut all the driving scene,
I will help you make this film. But I
think we have to lose the driving seat.
Thank you sir. Thank you. Good day.
But yes, New York was essential
in a crucial part of it.
And the cacophony of New York is,
uh,
only can be the cacophony of New York
and, and the streets and the people. And,
and it was essential that we were there,
but yes,
we did face, you faced certain
challenges every day, uh,
as
I did just until it just sharpens your
resolve to make a beautiful film and,
and to rise above it. I'm, and then a
little bit of Darwin was a, you know,
taught me because I didn't hear this
abuse that was yelled at my character w
just before our most crucial scene.
But some of my colleagues on the set dude,
and they were very distressed and,
and I said, come on, come on,
tell me. I heard something, um,
what happened? And they were
very reluctant to tell me. Um,
but in fact, two guys, uh,
shouted across to me whilst
I was in the dealership, uh,
helping Wendy by her red car and,
and they shouted,
he should be buying a fucking
camel, not a fucking car. And, um,
it's hard to say that it's
very distressing for the crew,
but actually I thought,
well then that's why you're here.
This is why we're making the film.
Come on. That's why you're here. Yeah,
no. So you know, you, you, you, you,
you think that, uh, all of New York, uh,
is, um, uh, advanced. You
want to believe you live,
live in a, uh, in a, uh, a
city that, uh, ignorance,
uh, it has escaped
ignorance, but it hasn't,
and it's ever present. And it's, um,
it's now the biggest problem in my,
in my opinion,
that we face in the world
today. So, um, so you've,
you've talked about this earlier, but
you guys actually were in a car, um,
that creates a certain sense of
intimacy for characters, for actors,
and you've also worked together before.
So was it easier to kind of slip into
this relationship between these two
characters are,
here's a paradox because we
weren't together so intimately.
I Dunno if you saw a movie,
we didn't call it a log.
We played lovers in that film.
You did move your hands on that one.
Seriously.
I had the first day go on Patty,
go pick up my life.
Um,
I met Sir Ben
and then we got naked and shot.
There's the sex scene.
That was the first thing we shot. I
mean, Isabelle just threw us together.
Best Way to do it.
Yeah.
Yes,
it was before lunch,
but he did it,
you know, it bonded us. It
gave us, uh, uh, uh, uh,
that's a lot.
Whoa.
Paradoxically, uh, what it allowed
us to do because we, you know,
we trusted each those scenes demand huge
trust and respect from one another and
we therefore knew the level of trust
that we had and we'll tap into his actos.
Therefore sitting the car between
takes,
we hardly spoke,
we kept it very separate.
We,
because we knew one another so well we,
and we have a great trust and uh,
but we wanted to make sure that savanna
and patty didn't blur the lines with
Wendy and Darwin,
that it was because the beauty,
the beauty of this film is it's very
subtly work a and charted and finally
etched of when the lines
blur with the two of them.
And we had to be very careful that those
lines blurred in the appropriate times.
And so we really,
we could trust one another enough.
It was a very quiet shoot.
We would sit often in silence in the car,
in between takes
that would trouble some people that
there and we completely trusted to be,
could be totally in repose
and still between takes,
which was a great gift.
So, yeah, no. Um, so the,
some of the other cast members
aren't here obviously, but,
but what was it like working with them?
Because a lot of them you've
worked with before, um,
did was that it's just an easy way to
kind of also slip into this sort of
familiar relationships.
Yes. I mean I um, uh, you know, having
been with this film for so long,
I had, you know, dreams of
the people I was hoping,
and I love Jake Weber
who played my husband.
We did this little film
called when to go together.
That was this little tiny horror film
director by, uh, Larry Fessenden.
We did it many,
many years ago and I thought he was
just the perfect mix of handsome and
academic and uh, just a fine, fine actor,
really fine actor.
And um,
and so it was a real treat to get to
work with him again and grace gummer um,
I met her six years ago
and six years ago I said,
if and when I get this movie made,
I want you to play my daughter
and thank God she still looks 18,
her good jeans. I was like, thank you. Uh,
but she's a beautiful,
stunning, a young actress.
And I was thankful that she did this and
you've got to work with gorgeous Serita,
terrific, gorgeous. Those were
actually some of my favorite,
almost uncomfortable scenes just
in the sense that he wanted,
I felt like he wanted so badly for
her to fit this kind of archetype,
bird or mold that maybe Wendy
was influencing a little bit,
much too quickly ahead in his
expectations yet. But it was,
it was wonderful for just to see someone
who was willing to step back and try.
Um, and then she goes to
college and she, you know,
she is led out into the
world by her friends,
by motto meets or in the
supermarket and goes to her house.
So, um, she does, she does take those one.
She in turn takes those baby
steps to being a liberation.
You got woman and I think she'll make it.
I think she'll do it.
She had some gumption and with the
support of her husband. Yup. And Yeah,
you get a sense with Serena that she
can kind of do anything. Yeah. Yeah.
I feel coke, but some, I mean I think
the thing for me with those was, um,
this,
this interesting non-existent language.
It was a language barrier but it wasn't
a language barrier and the scenes were
very interesting to watch in
the sense that, you know, it's,
it's somebody who wants this other person
so badly to communicate yet is having
trouble communicating maybe the emotions
and what they want out of their partner
themselves.
Um,
I don't know if he felt that way at all
or is that is just a beautiful acting
exercise where you have a very narrow
corridor of communication between the two
characters and therefore as actors,
you have to,
you have to be so accurate into getting
that on film down that tiny parameter of
communication that it absolutely
is this also where beautiful too.
Isabel question at our director that
we both worship and we love her.
She's Kathalyn and she,
uh,
she shoots with such a delicacy
and intimacy. You know,
she's the operator at like Soderbergh
and there's very few directors who are
operators, but she gets behind
that camera and she's able to,
you're never quite sure
sometimes where the camera is.
So the scene is just about life.
It's not about just blocking it out.
She rarely blocked something out
in a very strategic way. She just,
and it gives the scenes a delicacy
and an a true intimacy and that,
that we owe to Isabel
porch the camera and exactly the
right place every single time.
So that we as the actors
never have that anxiety. Well,
you wonder whether or not the director
has seen what you're trying to do. Get it.
It was not happening.
Sometimes they miss it completely or they
bring them their own agenda and their
own narrative and it doesn't,
they're not filming what's there.
And Isabelle films,
what's there
and she, she never misses
anything. Not a thing.
It's crazy there to watch her
shoot. It's, it's art too.
She puts the camera on like a Bungee
cord and it swings in and out silently.
It's, it's, it's something to
behold and it's her own style. Yeah.
And the DP is behind her and she just,
she starts to move and swoop the camera
on this like almost like little arm.
Yeah. And it's hitting on,
uh, engineering and art.
It's engineering and art and
it's, um, something we love. Yeah.
Um, so we'll take audience questions in
a moment if anyone wants the lineup. Um,
so I,
I have to ask,
do you yourselves drives and if so,
what was one of the memorable moments
about learning to drive? Well,
because you know, I become a
commodity, therefore I'm driven.
I'm driven to the studio.
I'm driven to here.
I drive less and less and less.
Where I do drive is in,
in Oxford.
Sherry is the English countryside
narrow country lanes. It,
it happens to be farming country.
So if I'm running an errand in,
in my vehicle, so it's a
land long wheelbase, Land
Rover. It's a really tough,
beautiful car. Um, I'm running
errands, they're working,
they're moving Matt, tons of
Hay. They're moving livestock.
They've got combine harvesters. I've
learnt to be alert to the narrow corners.
Anything could be horse riders,
anything could be coming round it.
I've learnt pullin Polin they're
working like the guys passed.
I love the etiquette of driving in the
English countryside is really something
beautiful. I don't, I, yeah,
I don't really drive anymore.
I drove for this movie and I joked with
my father that maybe when I come home to
New Orleans next time he'll teach
me to drive again. And he said,
I don't think so bad. Huh? There's
not enough red wine in the world.
And I think my final question
before we had the audience is, um,
what do you think was the
most rewarding part of,
was it just getting this film made for
you or has it been the journey afterwards
or it's telling the story
to people is a joy for me.
Um,
we're storytellers and to have
people touched by moved by amused,
by entertained, by what we do for
a living. It's absolutely glorious.
Uh, there was one moment early on
when we were shooting, you know,
like I said,
this has been a long journey for me to
get this film made and one day in pretty
much the first day and when we were both
in the makeup trailer and I was sitting
there and I was talking about Wendy and
my hair and what we're doing in makeup.
And I looked up and I saw Sir Bannon
is beautiful turban and he looked so
extraordinary and there he was.
He was Darwin.
And I looked at the two of us.
I thought, oh my God, it's,
we're here. He's here. Ron
is here, Wendy is here. Um,
we made it, we, we've got
the, we got this movie made.
It was a remarkable moment
that I'll never forget.
Wonderful.
Come on guys. Any audience
got da, we got one.
I have a question.
I wondered,
you've played these
extraordinarily diverse roles
recently and I wondered if you
had anything that was
discovered about yourself during these
roles of playing people from other
cultures. You know, what, what we,
what I discover,
uh,
is not necessarily anything
from the character.
I'm playing because my job as a portrait
artist is to put oil paint on the
canvas.
In other words,
it's pretty well a one way
street with some tiny exceptions.
But what I learned about being a,
an actor in the out in the world
is the politics of the film set.
Because I can tell you now every version
of human life is alive and well and
present on the film set.
And it's not just patty and I,
a lot of people behind the camera who
are trying to make something beautiful
with you and for you. And sometimes
they really get it wrong. Um,
we won't mention that the department
that consistently got it wrong,
but boy did that tax
our patients that what,
what it teaches you is to read,
read the signs from the film crew
patients and understand that everyone is
doing,
giving it their best shot.
And I learn a great deal from my journey
as an actor and not necessarily from
the characters I've played,
but from the process itself.
Thank you.
Hi, uh, uh, it's been a pleasure
listening to you and, uh,
I promise I'm going to waste a movie.
Okay. But I'm gonna to take this,
just one chance to say to serve Ben,
thank you so much for your great,
uh, acting in the movie. Gandhi.
Uh, it's one of the most popular
movies in India even today.
And I have two kids who
are a bit small right now,
but when they grow up to an age,
I'm going to like play this movie for
them because it tells so much about India
and I'm a great man.
So thank you so much and I want to
thank the organizers here for giving me,
giving me this opportunity. Thank
you. All the best. Thanks. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks.
So Patty,
you've sort of mentioned a few times
that you've been wanting to do this movie
for a long time. It's, it's
spends something to spend on
your mind. So how did you,
how, uh, what was it the, that um,
gave you the idea of wanting
to create this movie?
Yeah,
well, there was a beautiful, um,
essay by the Great Katha Pollitt.
I don't know if you knew,
she has been, um, is she, uh,
I'm sure some of you do. But,
um, she, uh, she had this beautiful essay,
semi autobiographical in the
New Yorker many, many years ago.
Uh, and I read it and I resonated
with me even many years,
many years ago,
and I thought it was at once,
uh,
this,
the humor and the pathos in equal
dose and sometimes simultaneous.
I, I just was taken by it. And, um,
I then found out that a woman named Dana
Dana Friedman had option the story and
turning it into a store, into a
script. And that Sarah Koenig,
she had written this script and then they
came to me and I thought I'd died and
gone to heaven. I said, oh my God, I
know this story. I love this story. Um,
that was long.
I joked that I was an ingenue when they
first brought me this to the script, but,
but I, um, I, uh,
I just loved,
I thought that the meeting of the minds
of Katha Pollitt and Sarah Koenig Shin,
I thought she would be captured
the, this story, the essence,
the heart of Katha Pollitt in the story.
And yet she opened it up and
made it her own and a beautiful,
a beautiful journey, um, of
these two people. And so why,
you know, that last
line, I say one of the,
pretty much the last line I say in
the film, you know, you're my faith.
And I had to remind myself of that,
that line almost daily, uh, uh,
that I had to have faith that,
that someone would,
would believe in this project that
someone, that all the, the, uh, the,
the movie gods would bring everybody
together at the right moment.
And that some person would say yes.
And that's what happened.
A man named Gabriel Hammond
and his brother Daniel Hammond,
we're starting a new production company
and they're young. They're like your age.
And these young men could
have chosen any film.
I mean, a film with storing
hot young stars, you know,
with models in Bikini's running around.
Um,
I can't believe I just reduce,
um,
but these young men chose,
uh, to make this film. Uh,
I went to dinner with Gabriel Hammond
and we had a three hour dinner at my,
my hangout. I live at this restaurant
called Cafe Lou in New York.
And he met me there and we sat in my
booth and we talked for three hours.
We never once talked about the movie.
We talked about his life,
his mother, his mother had passed away.
He loved the movie pieces of April.
And we talked about life and love and
growing up. And at the end of that,
the three hour dinner,
he said,
I want to make this film.
Mm hmm. He said yes.
Just took one person.
Oh,
good question.
Um,
you talk about reading this
article in the magazine.
How did that come about? I did
you just pick up them? No, I, I,
I'm obsessed with in New York.
I did tools. No, I'm obsessed
with the New Yorker. I,
I read the New Yorker,
uh, I, it's an addiction.
Um, but, uh, here we go to jail.
The Light, the manuscript that when did
it leaves in the back of the carb. Yeah.
Is there a possibility ability that you
might have missed reading that story?
Just, you know, you may not
have got the New Yorker on that,
that additional, that's very
possible. Yeah. But I didn't, yeah,
that's the important thing. Yeah.
I read it and I saved it. Well,
I save, I had, I had boxes of in New
York or I wouldn't know the New Yorker.
I wouldn't throw them out.
I eventually people said,
petty takes the New
Yorkers out of your hands.
Just give me the New Yorker
and giving me. But I, um, I, I,
I did,
I did happen to read this story and I,
um,
that's really how it happened.
But it wasn't that unusual because I, I
was, I always read the New York. Right,
right,
right.
Hi, thanks for coming out today. Uh, I had
a question sort of on acting mythology.
So, you know, it seems
like you're both very, uh,
in tune with these characters that
you play and you know, as the movie,
the completion of the movie and
then you move on away from it,
it wouldn't do you separate yourself
from those characters that you played and
sort of become Sir Ben and Patty
again and move on to other roles.
The W when I was at school,
I studied physics and there
is a law in physics which,
which, um, confronts elasticity.
And the law says that if you stretch
something beyond its point of elasticity,
it's point of elasticity. I have a
physicist to hit nodding on my left.
It will not shrink back
to its original shape.
So although we throw
ourselves into our roads,
we have developed a technique.
We have developed boundaries,
which we alluded to earlier.
And we are,
there's something in our DNA, in our,
in our reactive bodies that says,
well,
if you go there,
you will have passed your point of
elasticity and you will not shrink back.
And fortunately, um, I know
it doesn't always happen.
There are some actors who
will get terribly distressed,
uh, they resort to drugs,
to alcohol to compensate,
to try and get back to,
to cope with this rather dangerous
thing that we're playing with.
We are playing with that point
of elasticity. And, um, for me,
because I have a rather forensic
approach to my, to my work, um, it,
it does, I know the is shrinking
back. I can feel it even,
you know, after every take, after
every take, it has to come back for me.
Some people like to stay in
the stretch zone all day.
I come back to me and then take a
jump to the next, to the next take.
I think, um, uh, for me as, as I work a,
the emotional life of a character, I, Eh,
what is essential for me is to marry
it to the emotional life that I have.
So I have that well available
and readily available.
So it is,
it's difficult at the end of each day
when you're doing very emotional scenes.
It's never easy, but if
it's easy, you should,
I've often thought if it's ever
easy, I shouldn't be doing this. Um,
uh,
but I will say when a movie is over,
there's a small part of you.
For me that's always been given
away that you'll never get back.
And it is, um, it's just,
that's part of the, that comes with a job
in a way. It's just, it's a small little,
there's something you've given away.
There's something you've
sacrificed in some way for this.
And it just, it, it's just, it happens.
And I find I've now learned to find
peace with that and realize that,
you know, the recovery
process is, uh, it's, is,
is slow, but it does, it will come.
But it is more info
when, when you end, uh,
these projects, it's, it's for me. Um,
I just finished doing the elephant man.
I did it on Broadway
and then I took it to,
with Bradley Cooper to London and I
just closed the play two weeks ago.
And here I am in Palo Alto
and I haven't quite mourn the loss of
Mrs Kendall and that whole journey with
the elephant man because I came straight
into doing press and maybe that's good.
Maybe I'll just, I won't have that, that,
that mournful process.
I don't know if you,
when I get home to New
York after all of this,
I'm going to sit in my bed
and drink bourbon. I don't
know. I think I'm probably going
to do a celebratory Bourbon,
you know? Okay. Celebratory Bourbon.
Yeah. Anyway, thank you so much Bryce.
He mentions the word sacrifice
in response to your question,
but also there's another word
that you could also apply,
which is that you share and
you share with audiences.
And that's why that young woman cried
because you are getting amazing responses
from people who are sharing what you do.
So I don't sacrifice would go into
the vacuum. Yours doesn't. Yeah,
no, no. I mean it's just, it's a
very life affirming. Well, yes.
I mean you give up a part of yourself for
the greater good. Yeah. That's what it,
oh, no, it's a beautiful thing.
Beautiful. It's a beautiful thing. I mean,
when it works, there are times
when no, I mean, in this film,
the response we've gotten
has been, um, it's,
it's been,
it's been great.
I have a question.
Um,
so I guess one of the things that being
accomplished actors who gives you is a
very strong platform to have
influence across the world on masses.
I'm a Sikh and I want to tell you
this is a movie Debbie celebrate,
um, in our community. Um,
one of the things it does is it helps
some of the lesser known religions kind of
highlight.
And the question I have for you guys
is do you at a personal level have a
humanistic goal of when
you play a such rules,
does it satisfy an innate desire
to do something for the humanity,
you know, across that cuts across
geographical lines, country lines,
and you know, it's going to be
celebrated perhaps more so in a vase,
smaller section of the
the world. Um, you know,
and still be able to sort
of have the influence.
I think that we are distant
descendants from something tribally,
absolutely essential. And that is that
we are descendants of the ancient,
ancient,
ancient storyteller who used to light a
fire and get the tribe around him or her
and comfort them in the night.
Tell them very reassuring,
beautiful stories.
So that they would have the confidence
to know that the night would pass,
the sun would come up again.
And I'm sure in our DNA that
both patty and I are distant,
distant, distant descendants from
the healist Sharman storyteller.
I'm sure we are. And certainly, um, uh,
W I think we're aware that,
that you drop a pebble into the water
and the ripples can be extraordinary. Um,
I don't think we strive to do that,
but I think it comes with the job.
Would you agree?
Yes. But I have to say
through what you just said,
made the whole nine years
that journey worth it.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm patty. This, um,
this film clearly has been a very long
coming goal for you and now that you've
finally achieved it.
I was just wondering if there's some
other project that you feel just as
passionate about that is next on the list.
Yes, I do. I have another, I have
another long journey of a film,
uh, about, uh,
my next journey is to make a movie about
this fabulous woman from the forties,
thirties, forties, 50s
named Tallulah Bankhead.
If you don't know who she
is, Google her. Uh, uh,
she was, um, quite a character,
a brilliant, funny woman,
a great actress. And, and, uh, Phil did,
she really defined the word
Joie de vivre. And, uh, she, uh,
she broke all the boundaries and
broke all the rules in Hollywood.
She's just someone I've wanted to play
and you have to have a very deep voice.
And, uh, and I'm, I'm, I'm
pretty much there. And, uh,
so, uh, it's just, she's a
woman that fascinates me. Um,
she was, uh, omnivorous
and a carnivorous. She was,
she, uh, she wanted everything in life
and every person, male, female, she,
um, I'm, I'm looking forward to,
that's the next journey.
So beautiful script. Uh,
I'm in the process of getting that
together and to make that very cool.
Thank you. Wish me, please say,
hopefully it won't be nine years.
Good luck. Thank you. Well, thank you
so much.
[inaudible].
Thank you both so much for joining us
today and I hope everyone enjoys the film
very much. Thank you so much. You guys.